per chunk hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to SCP
containment breach now I know it's been
a while since the last episode so let me
get you caught back up we JA
hahahahahaha contained radical Larry and
again I apologize for the delay it's
like three different games that I really
wanted to play suddenly came out all at
once but I intend to get back into the
series that I always wanted to play
right soon so with that being said we're
going to dive back into this terrible
terrible world and you can see he's in
there he's in that horrible box of death
and destruction with that other person
I'm going to assume that they're dead
now because that would be merciful but I
don't think the radical Larry can
transfer into his pocket dimension which
where he pulls you into if he actually
makes contact with you so I'm just
assuming I'm just assuming that
everything is hunky-dory with that and
we're going to be okay but I don't
remember where we are exactly because
again it's been a while so I can't
recall if Radek larry is now good and
we're happy with that or if there's some
other horrible entity here then we need
to deal with because there is wait let's
just double check because I need to know
if you're in okay so there is this
elevator and I think at the bottom of
this elevator was the horrible
monstrosity known as the plague doctor
that wanted to turn me into one of his
zombies by giving me the quote-unquote
cure so we're going to see if he was all
legit about that and we're going to go
down and meet him again because I
no no no how can I get by no no [ __ ]
no no no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
kidding oh god help me
how well I didn't do well there
oh okay alright so apparently mr. Senor
plague doctor sure found it easy to call
that elevator back down and then poke me
with the little finger and I was done so
right then and there and I don't think
I'm gonna be able to run around and so
ring around that posey pocketful [ __ ]
you and then go to hell and I can't damn
it okay so the next thing that we need
to do we need to go in a different
direction because that Elliot is full of
[ __ ] and what the [ __ ] is going on there
what is any of that we're not yeah we
really have only one way to go and that
is to go back through these areas here
but I do have to be mindful because oh I
thought I put on the wrong one for a
second there I do not want to go to that
world unless maybe I do unless there's a
reason for me to go on that world but I
don't think there might be just yet so
I'm going to keep moving forward with no
Billy to be found here and also I don't
know what the hell's down there because
we got all these ways to go that don't
exactly show us the right path all the
time can I close the goddamn door thank
you hi where am I now okay hello oh good
still right on top of me are they where
the hell are
[Music]
well I think I just found our you are
okay so long as I keep my head before
why are you down there why are you down
there why are you down there what are
you doing it am I able to see his face
from here I'm just wondering what he's
doing down there and how we got there
like he's walking into a wall creep
alike
I'm just gonna ignore that did I ignore
that one anyone else here okay so we're
okay so we figured out where he was the
crying [ __ ] babies down in the pit
being a little [ __ ]
oh he's nearby okay we're fine oh four
nine is still creeping around but we
knew that okay so there's got to be
another way to go here there's got to be
like another elevator that I can take
because if there's not then I'm kind of
screwed ain't I I'm just a little bit
schooled oh oh wait no no is this the
elevator that called the elders oh I
don't like this I don't like this okay
all right I'm gonna trust you we're
going to go down here we're gonna have a
good old time and there's not going to
be a plague doctor where am i where am i
oh no no no no no where am I
I really hope that's all we did it did
it did it did it did it did it did okay
I gotta get out of this elevators good
luck get into it
[ __ ] hell that doesn't help anybody
at all okay goodbye
[ __ ] [ __ ] no what is this well
it's women's later palm on the scanner
DNA does not match known sample access
Deniz all right oh hi okay goodbye uh
all right then why is uh what Billy just
standing over there in the darkness
Billy on a closes darn you because [ __ ]
you oh that's the way to the computer
room that's what I need okay that was a
long blink all right so you're there
what's this oh the Omega warhead
silo that's just a little thing all
righty then hang on a second here
dr. Elle's note aversion delight my foot
he doesn't mind blade he's never had any
issue with light never ever never he
just doesn't like to talk all at once no
not at all not at all it there were
tests done during a breach some girly
item that could see things she watched
it saw it was seen saw he likes to hurt
or maybe he likes he just likes he
doesn't retreat from the light he just
stops being it for a while he slides
back and hides and counts to ten again
begin again and off he goes
only nobody is ever hit again he takes
his toys and the players and he goes
home okay I'm gonna go down I'm gonna go
down into the Omega warhead silo
that's that song he's already fun plates
go with the Duke look applause all of
these roads but that's a whole nother
story okay hello oh I hear you creeping
around up there is you not happy about
me being here okay I don't think I'm
gonna set it off unless I can save and
show you guys what that's all about
but if I can close that off maybe just
maybe up now can't save I don't think
I'm gonna blow everybody here
he drops add this up Oh
alpha warheads for 1 kiloton hydrogen
bombs designed to demolish the area
above the facility without causing major
damage to the underground parts ah ok
blast shield wait oh that's right the
alpha warheads and in the Omega warheads
it's the difference between 4 1 kiloton
hydrogen bombs and then a five Megaton
hydrogen bomb designed to demolish
everything within a five-mile radius
requires 505 level authorization so if I
wanted to if I wanted to I could just
blow us all the [ __ ] or wait no they're
actually already turned on I feel
slightly encumbered but that's ok
because now I got a bulletproof vest
which is good so if I wanted to I could
turn these off that's right to one of
the endings if I turn this off if
containment cannot be reset they will
detonate these warheads so I'm gonna
turn them off cuz at least I can't blow
us all to smitheroons and I think I
think that's what the computer wanted me
to do in the first place that's right
ooh all right you did make sure that no
Billy's gonna be ok right
no I didn't know invited guests in the
elevator place a blink block before I
get in there hello hello hello spring
sprung ok you're still here apparently
somewhere whoa uh-oh
[Music]
memory access violation okay I deserve
that you need to trust it you need to
trust it you need to trust it you need
to trust it you need to trust you need
to trust I need to trust what what do I
need to trust are you talking about the
computer you talking about the computer
oh this computer an exiting sorcerer
microcomputer built in 1978 that has
artificial intelligence
okay so Billy's in here maybe wait am I
going the right way yeah I'm going the
right way
all right so Billy's over here somewhere
Sam buddy somewhere over here I think on
the other side of this door oh yeah oh I
see you over there okay you are over
there right yes you are all right
bling blong no blink blink flunk okay
you come over here huh how about that
yeah you want some of me yeah that's too
close
why is this door locked okay swing
o'clock that's cool
slink oh boy okay I'm watching you I'm
watching you Wazowski always watching or
two now I got a mind to doors far enough
away all right I'm good I think I'm good
just in case three doors oh hi sentient
object you say well here we go then
hello would you like to talk I bet you
would
hello oh hi dead body how you doing how
was you killed yes score eek oh oh
squeeze or someone's not happy here so I
got a turn off
I forgot I need to turn off remote door
control to this area
how do I do that again I can't quite
remember okay
memory access violation okay I think
that's a sign and I'm gonna end this
episode here because holy [ __ ] okay
so oh thank you everybody so much for
watching I think I need a break after
that one my heart literally stopped for
a full second there huh that might have
been one of the biggest jump scares I've
ever had in like my entire career doing
these or games but either way
i'ma go lie down for a second cuz oh and
I think some of you might need to lie
down too so thank you everybody so much
for watching uh I'll get back to this
real soon we'll have more regular
episodes of this don't you worry let me
know how I did it becomes blown
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]